[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview j'ai
l'honneur de m'entretenir avec ernestine
ronai illustres figures du féminisme en
france elle se bat depuis plus de 30 ans
contre les violences faites aux femmes
et les féminicides bonjour rien estime
rené merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
vous êtes responsable de l'observatoire
départemental des violences envers les
femmes de seine-saint-denis également
membre du haut conseil à l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes
ernestine ronai un féminicide et commis
tous les deux à trois jours en france
actuellement pourquoi il joue ton encore
à protéger totalement les femmes
je pense qu'on n'a pas encore pris
conscience de la dangerosité des hommes
violents
c'est sans doute la première raison est
la plus importante quand je dis on c'est
à la fois la société toute la société
nous tous et probablement aussi les
forces de sécurité et la justice et donc
de ce fait évidemment les femmes peuvent
tuer parce que il faut prendre en compte
les violences
dès les premières violences révéler si
on veut avoir moins de féminicide dans
notre pays il faut qu'on prenne en
compte les violences dès les premières
violences révéler pourquoi parce que les
femmes hésitent à révéler les violences
ça ne vient pas tout de suite
donc quand c'est les premières violences
révélé ce ne sont absolument pas les
premières violences subies ça c'est la
première raison et puis la deuxième
c'est que souvent elles disent beaucoup
moins que ce qu'elle subisse en réalité
par exemple les violences psychologiques
sont souvent minimisé les violences
sexuelles dans cap du couple sont
également minimisé ce qui vient d'abord
c'est la violence physique et à ce
moment là elles vont demander de l'aide
et donc c'est ça le problème que nous
avons dans notre pays
c'est à la fois qu' il faut prendre en
compte les premières violences ça s'est
révélé
et puis la deuxième sans doute c'est
qu'il faut croire les femmes et là
encore nous avons quelques soucis parce
que je pense qu'encore aujourd'hui on ne
croit pas les femmes lorsqu'elles révèle
les violences mais là vos propos font
écho aux meurtres de magali blandin qui
a été tuée par son ex alors même qu'elle
avait porté plainte
est ce que ça vous rend encore plus en
colère parce que là il y as peut-être
faillite des institutions donc sans
doute à vérifier
et disons mais disons qu'en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que les plaintes quand
une dame vient révéler violence les
plaintes doivent être prises au sérieux
et donc croire la dame pour la protéger
et en fait la classer sans suite la
plainte classée sans suite ça veut dire
qu'il y avait pas suffisamment
d'éléments mais évidemment les éléments
faut les chercher
et depuis quelques années nous avons
amélioré la formation des gendarmes des
policiers dans l'audition des victimes
il ya maintenant des protocoles
d'auditions qui permette que les
questions soient posées davantage et
donc ensuite il ya une des enquêtes une
bonne audition donnera des enquêtes et
des enquêtes donneront des poursuites
par la justice derrière ou d'ailleurs
vous avez vous même rédigé une trame
pour cette audition à l'adresse des
policiers des gendarmes qui les font et
alors voilà exactement
oui alors justement vous appelez un
principe de précaution c'est un principe
de précaution dans l' enquête dans le le
recueil des données ou dans des systèmes
qui se mettrait en place tout de suite
après la plainte
la question c'est plutôt la question de
protéger les femmes dès qu'elles
révèlent des violences dans le cadre
d'un principe de précaution
c'est à dire croire les femmes
considérées que lorsqu'elle parle
lorsqu'elle révèle des violences eh bien
il ya réellement des violences et nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité
donc celle qui révèle il faut vraiment
les croire et les protéger après ça sera
une deuxième question est ce qu'on va
sanctionner l'agresseur mais au moins
déjà protéger la victime ayant ya une un
dispositif dans la loi française qui
s'appelle l' ordonnance de protection
qui existe depuis 2010 et l' ordonnance
de protection est exactement fait pour
ça je révèle des violences qu'on dit
vraisemblable donc pas forcément déjà
avérées du fait d'une enquête de police
en tout cas vraisemblable et à ce
moment-là il yal ordonnance de
protection qui peut protéger les femmes
victimes
or on n'a que que 4000 demandes
ordonnance de protection et la moitié
seulement accordé 2000 donc on voit
qu'on est assez loin parce que justement
on a encore un problème pour penser la
dangerosité pour penser qu est ce que ça
veut dire des violences vraisemblable et
moi je considère que lorsque la dame
révèle des violences vraisemblable il ya
forcément du danger et donc il faut
forcément la protéger et la loi
française dit violence vraisemblable et
danger et moi je pense qu'il faut
mélanger les deux est considéré que
lorsqu'il ya des violences vraisemblable
ya forcément du danger et d'ailleurs la
justice au moment d'ouverture du
grenelle avait reconnu cela et dans un
guide qui est publié on parle on écrit
clairement que lorsqu'il ya des
violences vraisemblable il ya du danger
mais ce n'est pas toujours appliquée par
les magistrats
c'est notre problème vous avez parlé de
ces auditions qui sont mieux fait
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour une part il
ya également des améliorations qui sont
importés comme par exemple commissariat
de nanterre un bouton spécifique pour
que les femmes à être déposés sans
redouter quelque chose
quels autres améliorations avez vous
noté moi je pense que l'amélioration la
plus importante c'est la formation des
magistrats des policiers et des
gendarmes
et c'est le skill finalement va faire
que les choses vont bouger
et puis les magistrats les policiers les
gendarmes font partie de la société et
notre société progresse dans la
compréhension de la dangerosité des
violences conjugales et donc je pense
qu'on va s'améliorer sur ce sur cette
île sur la protection des femmes du fait
que la société aussi progresse
l'art en 2017 emmanuel macron avait
parlé de l'égalité hommes femmes comme
de la grande cause du quinquennat avec
un pilier la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes
est ce que vous trouvez que justement
cette lutte a été à la hauteur ces
dernières années on peut pas vraiment
dire qu'elle a été à la hauteur mais on
peut dit
que la société ces dernières années
c'est vraiment mobilisés et le fait qu'
on compte les féminicides 1
les associations de femmes comptent les
féminicides 1 a permis une meilleure
compréhension et donc en 2019
quand il ya eu une explosion une
augmentation très importante des
violences faites aux femmes
nous avons eu le grenelle de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
organisée par le gouvernement qui a
permis de penser la dangerosité première
chose deuxième chose il ya eu un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui sont mis en
place la loi a continué à avancer vous
savez la loi je considère que c'est du
gagne terrain c'est un puzzle et à
chaque fois on rajoute une pièce et puis
ce qui manque cruellement
je pensais la question des moyens au
moment où on dit cependant on dépense
des milliards pour plein de choses à
juste titre c'est pas du tout ce que je
mets en cause bien sûr je pense que ce
que nous portons avec le haut conseil à
l'égalité femmes-hommes avec la
fondation des femmes avec la délégation
aux droits des femmes du conseil
économique social et environnemental
c'est la demande d'un milliard par an
pour les violences faites aux femmes
et nous en sommes très loin même on peut
considérer qu' à peu près 3 370 millions
tous ministères confondus
et quand même je vais vous donner le
chiffre de ce que le ministère odeur à
l'égalité femmes-hommes a comme moyen
sur cette lutte 42 milliards millions
justement pas des milliards des millions
donc c'est le plus petit budget qui est
du budget national
donc on voit bien qu'on est quand même
encore très loin très loin de ce qui est
nécessaire pour vraiment pouvoir avoir
les moyens de protéger les femmes
en effet puisque en 2019 lors du
grenelle des violences conjugales les
associations avaient tout de suite
répliqué en disant qu'il y avait un
manque de moyens d'accompagnement c'est
aussi votre bilan donc il ya un manque
de moyens notamment pour les
associations bien sûr mais aussi pour
créer des dispositifs par exemple la
question de l'hébergement
est une question cruciale la ministre va
annoncer aujourd'hui qu'ils amis
l'hébergement supplémentaires c'est
mieux que rien bien sûr je vais pas dire
que c'est rien mais on voit bien que
c'est très insuffisant me libère je mens
ces dix par département à peu près et on
voit on sait par exemple que dans les
outre-mer qui sont des départements
français on manque cruellement de places
d'hébergement mais on sait aussi qu'il
ya un certain nombre de départements qui
n'en n'ont pas et puis l'autre élément
c'est qu'il faut des hébergements
spécialisée avec des personnels formés
et non mixtes
parce qu'une femme qui a subi des
violences si elle se retrouve avec des
sdf des sortants de prison
des personnes désocialisées bien sûr il
faut des hébergements pour ces gens là
mais il faut aussi des pertes d
hébergement spécialisés avec un
personnel formé qui va aider cette femme
à sortir des violences et à reprendre sa
vie en main c'est ce qu'on lui souhaite
bien sûr on va parler de votre parcours
ernestine ronai vous avez tout d'abord
été institutrice directrice d'école
psychologue scolaire et au fil du temps
vous êtes aperçu que derrière les
situations d'échec scolaire des enfants
il y avait bien souvent des violences
conjugales est ce que c'est cela qui a
créé un déclic pour vous engager plus
avant
oui c'est pour moi ça a été très
important j'ai deux périodes dans ma
carrière professionnelle de psychologues
de l'éducation une première période je
ne connais pas les violences donc je
n'en ai pas j'ai eu un enfant victime
fac est né d'un viol dont la maman était
victime d'un viol un seul jeu j'arrête
la psychologie pendant un moment et je
dis un secrétaire national donc de
femmes solidaires et à ce moment là
j'apprends la violence par les femmes
elles-mêmes c'est elle qui m'ont appris
la violence je forme des jeunes je
laisse la place aux jeunes et je
reprends mon métier de psychologue et à
ce moment là je questionne
systématiquement toutes les mères qui
viennent seuls parce que la pub 80 % des
mères quand on convoque monsieur et
madame c'est madame qui arrive donc dans
80% des cas je peux poser la question et
ma question c'était escales de la
violence à la maison et la dame dizaine
opa sur mon enfant et je disais et sur
vous
et j'ai fini ma carrière en 2007 avec
une maman sur deux qui disaient oui qui
répondait oui
et lorsque j'ai été nommée coordinatrice
nationale de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes à la mission
interministérielle de protection des
femmes j'ai mis en place dans le cadre
de la formation
1 comment je vais dire une préconisation
qui est le questionnement systématique
chaque femme rencontrée conçoit un
médecin une sage-femme une infirmière un
podologue ou une podologue une
travailleuse sociale une assistante
sociale
on pose la question à la dame est ce que
vous avez été victime de violences et
les dames
peut-être qu'il ya une dame qui dira non
et qui reviendra comme ça m'est arrivé
dix minutes après en me disant vous
m'avez posé une question reposez moi la
question ou deux ans après comme ça
m'est également arrivé
une dame qui revient taillade et caetera
et qui me dit vous m'aviez demandé il ya
deux ans si j'étais victime est
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire que oui je
l'étais mais à l'époque je vous ai
répondu non et finalement ça aide à la
révélation est donc on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence et bien
la question c'est que les professionnels
qui accueille les femmes osent parler
des violences brise le silence pour
protéger les femmes c'est ça l'objectif
il faut absolument protéger les femmes
qu un véritable fléau
merci à décines rhône et on va juste
marqué une courte pause on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
ernestine rené pionnière dans la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
ernestine ronai vous avez pris la tête
de l'observatoire départemental des
violences envers les femmes de seine
saint denis
qu'est-ce que se passait-il avant votre
arrivée
comparé à maintenant alors c'était il ya
longtemps c'était en 2002 en 2002 il ya
beaucoup de lois qui n'existait pas qui
existe aujourd'hui
ce qui s'est passé ce qui se passait en
2002 on va dire c'est que finalement on
parle est relativement peu des violences
faites aux femmes premiers éléments il y
avait relativement peu dispositif de
protection
deuxième élément est la justice quand je
suis arrivé dans ce département étaient
peu à l'écouté des femmes victimes de
violence arrivent en 2005 françois melin
ce comme procureur et patrick poirret
comme procureur adjoint et philippe
jeannin comme président du tribunal
et ça a changé la donne parce qu'à ce
moment là c'est établi un véritable
partenariat entre la justice et
l'observatoire et du coup nous avons été
productif ensemble de dispositifs
nouveaux
je crois que c'est ce qui marque
l'histoire de ce département et de cet
observatoire
c'est vraiment le partenariat justice
observatoire avec tous les autres
partenaires les associations bien sûr
les services du département l'aide
sociale à l'enfance service social
et puis pmi essentiellement et puis les
services de l'état donc la justice la
police pour nous ça a été fondamental
c'est arrivé deux magistrats qui ont
souhaité s'impliquer dans la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
ça a tout changé quand on parle de
violence est ce qu'on met sur le même
plan des violences physiques sexuelles
psychologiques
on agit d la violence psychologique
alors la violence psychologique est
encore peu reconnu peu reconnu par les
femmes elles-mêmes tu es nul tu sais
rien faire t'es qu'une merde l'insultent
chienne ou autre chose put finalement on
l'entend mais on considère pas encore
qu'il s'agit d'une violence souvent
c'est rentré dans le code pénal en 2010
harcèlement moral dans le couple mais
aujourd'hui encore il ya peu de
condamnations et c'est insuffisamment
reconnues dans toutes les formations que
je peux faire à l'école nationale de la
magistrature auprès de la gendarmerie
nationale ou la police nationale
j'insiste là dessus parce que finalement
la violence psychologique peut conduire
à la mort comme la violence physique par
suicides ou tentatives de suicide avec
après des invalidités terrible donc
c'est aussi grave mais peu entendu
encore aujourd'hui malheureusement donc
on a encore du progrès on a une marge de
progrès après la violence sexuelle dans
le couple est également insuffisamment
reconnues pourquoi parce que on
considère encore le devoir conjugal
si on est ensemble dans un couple c'est
qu'on a des relations sexuelles et donc
le fait de ne pas de ne pas vouloir
d'une relation sexuelle est encore peu
reconnu si je peux donner un exemple
dans un couple ordinaire dans nos
couples j'ai envie il a pas envie je le
mets en route ça marche tant mieux ça
marche pas je m'arrête
inversement il a envie j'ai pas envie il
va essayer de me mettre en route ça
marche tant mieux ça marche pas il va
s'arrêter
ça c'est un couple ordinaire par contre
dans un courrier de la violence c'est
lui qui décide si on a des relations
sexuelles quel type de relation sexuelle
on a j'ai rien contre aucune forme de de
relations sexuelles à condition qu'on
soit d'accord tous les deux mais lui il
va décider de comment on fait et puis il
va décider si je prends une
contraception pas si j'ai une ivg ou pas
si on a un enfant pas le lieu de
décision c'est lui le lieu du pouvoir le
lieu la domination de ses lui et moi je
suis comme une chose pour lui et c'est
ça qui fait très mal aux femmes mais qui
n'est pas toujours bien reconnu par elle
même et pas toujours bien sûr par la
justice puisque l'épreuve d'une d'un
viol conjugal sont plus compliqués à
faire ça suppose d'écouter la dame et
d'entendre et d'inscrire ces violences
sexuelles
l'ensemble du continuum des violences
après on a tout ce qui est violent ce
matériel il prend ma carte bleue
il me prend ma carte vitale et me prends
mes papiers si cheveux étrangères mes
diplômes si on a des diplômes
donc il prend le contrôle de ma vie
c'est ça qui font entendre et enfin
arrive la violence physique
celle ci elle est reconnue à la fois par
les femmes par les forces de sécurité
par tout le monde
si j'ai un oeil au beurre noir on va le
voir ça va être reconnu évidemment on
voit bien que tout ce qui précède qui
est vraiment un continuum va faire que
cette violence physique va être reconnu
et va augmenter en intensité et donc va
devenir de plus en plus dangereuse et
souvent c'est au moment de cette
dangerosité qu'on va donner un téléphone
grave danger à une dame victime pour
qu'elle puisse se protéger
alors justement le fameux téléphone
grave danger vous en avez été
l'initiatrice des 2009 en seine saint
denis un dispositif qui ensuite est
appliquée à partir de 2014
quelles sont quel est le bilan de cette
initiative
et bien si je prends en
seine-saint-denis on a aujourd'hui plus
de 300 femmes qui ont été protégés et
aucune n'a été tué donc on va dire c'est
vraiment très efficace
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est au niveau national on a eu
je crois deux femmes qui ont été tués
avec le téléphone grave danger parce que
évidemment c'est pas une armure et
monsieur peut empêcher madame d'appuyer
sur le bouton donc mais disons
globalement ce je pense que ça a sauvé
beaucoup de vies vraiment ma passion
naît on va aujourd'hui c'est à ce même
rooney oui c'est un téléphone sur lequel
existe une touche qui prévient des
services qui peuvent appeler tout de
suite les forces de police et donc
fatalement qui peuvent éloigner l'homme
qui s'est approché de la femme en danger
qui arrive très vite c'est ça l'intérêt
c'est que et c'est le procureur de la
république qui attribue le téléphone
c'est à dire que à partir du moment où
c'est procureur de la république
les forces de sécurité sont prévenus et
interviennent systématiquement lorsque
une dame
appuyez sur le bouton
donc s'est appuyé sur le bouton après
neuf et doute par alliance assistance
donc ça c'est très important
cette ce dispositif ses 1700 un peu plus
de 1700 femmes qui aujourd'hui en
bénéficient ce qui est important
je pense que ça devrait encore monter en
intensité si je prends l'exemple de
l'espagne on est à 15 milles donc vous
voyez on est un peu loi du nombre
donc on a vraiment besoin de continuer à
augmenter le nombre de femmes protéger
arrêté d'hésiter à attribuer le
téléphone mais de la tribu est largement
à des femmes en danger en grave danger
1 c'est ça l'idée c'est à dire qu'on a
un continuum on a l'ordonance de
protection dès les premières violences
dans ma tête
comment ça devrait se faire ensuite
quand il ya du grave danger
le téléphone grave danger est peut-être
le bracelet anti rapprochement comme il
ya des du très très très très grand
danger
voilà il vient juste d'être mis en place
qu'en pensez vous eh bien je pense que
c'est très bien pour un sortant de
prison
c'est à dire que c'est très adapté pour
un sortant de prison de sa prison il a
dit à la dame
je vais te tuer donc évidemment on prend
au sérieux sa menace
dès que je sors je te tue là je pense
que telle et le bracelet anti
rapprochement est très efficace c'est
quoi le bracelet anti rapprochement
c'est monsieur k un bracelet et un
boîtier et madame qui est un boîtier ils
sont géolocalisées en permanence et
c'est là la distance entre les deux qui
est prise en compte
ce qui signifie que si on le donne trop
tôt dans la procédure
ça va pas fonctionner parce que ça va
mettre encore en contact l'agresseur et
la victime en permanence c'est à dire
que la victime va se demander en
permanence où il est et l'agresseur va
se demander en permanence où elle est or
notre problème dans les violences
conjugales
c'est de défaire l'emprise de cette dame
elle est sous emprise il faut défaire
l'emprise donc il faut pas qu'elle pense
toujours à son agresseur donc c'est très
bien
dans le cadre pénal c'est très bien dans
le cadre d'un très très très grand
dangereux c'est inadapté de mon point de
vue
dans le cadre de l' ordonnance de
protection la loi le permet mais ça me
paraît totalement inadapté et d'ailleurs
il ya très peu de deux bracelets
actuellement mise en circulation du fait
qu' il faut je pense que les magistrats
sont quand même assez conscients qu'il
faut du très grand danger parce que
c'est géolocalisation en permanence et
il ya des femmes d'ailleurs qui à
pontoise par exemple ont rendu leur
téléphone parce qu'elle ne supportait
pas d'être tout le temps géolocalisés et
que le bazar sonne comme ceux se
rapprochait de la zone d' alerte c'était
trop dur pour elle le téléphone grave
danger à l'intérêt que c'est la dame qui
appuient
c'est elle qui décide je dis d'habitude
que c'est elle qui prend sa protection
en main physiquement avec son téléphone
le bracelet anti rapprochement ça se
passe en dehors de moi je je suis donc
c'est très bien si c'est un très grand
dangereux sinon je pense que c'est pas
adapté on va parler maintenant de l'âge
du consentement qui est de retour chez
les parlementaires avec on l'espère une
loi prochaine pour statuer que en
dessous de 15 ans et bien un mineur
n'est pas consentant vous y tenez cela
vous tenait beaucoup à coeur
effectivement dès 2016 dans le cadre de
la commission violence du haut conseil
nous avons mis dans le débat la question
de créer un seuil d'âge
donc je suis très contente que ya un
seuil d'âge qui soit maintenant établie
dans la loi 15 ans je veux dire qu'il ne
s'agit pas de consentement
parce que nous ne pouvons pas considérer
qu'un enfant est consentant à une 1
action qu elle avec un majeur quel que
soit ce majeur on ne peut pas penser
qu'un enfant à la la maturité affective
cognitive pour penser l'acte sexuel
donc il s'agit pas de consentement nous
considérons que de toute façon l'enfant
est contraint à l'acte sexuel par le
majeur et dans les livres qui sont
sortis récemment
on le voit très bien que ce soit celui
de camille kouchner celui de vanessa
spring aura vanessa springer à une
formule que j'aime beaucoup dans son
livre le consentement elle dit
comment est ce que j'ai pu penser que
j'étais consentante
c'est à la scea l'adulte de penser le
sujet c'est à lui de ceux de se contenir
si je peux dire pour ne pas passer à
l'acte et je trouve que sa formule est
excellente
parce que c'est vraiment de ça qu'il
s'agit c'est l'adulte
le majeur qui doit penser l'acte et le
mineur n'est pas en capacité de penser
là c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que nous
parlons de présomption de contrainte et
non pas de consentement la loi
d'ailleurs de 1980 sur le viol que
j'aime beaucoup que je rappelle souvent
elle dit tout acte de pénétration
sexuelle par quelques moyens que ce soit
par vieux par violence menace contrainte
surprise c'est à dire qu'elle nous
demande de regarder l'agresseur et de
pas regarder la victime
quels sont les moyens que l'agresseur
mais en oeuvre pour arriver à ses fins
pour violées ou agressées sexuellement
que ce soit d'ailleurs un majeur ou un
mineur et pour moi c'est très important
parce que souvent on met toute la
responsabilité sur la victime
la jupe trop courte elle a pas crier
elle a pas l ai pas partie et c'est
alors que c'est la question
de quels sont les moyens que l'agresseur
a mis en oeuvre qui doit être posée et
la loi le dis très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement en dix ans elle
a consenti elle avait bu ben non c'est
elle a bu elle n'est pas en capacité
c'est la surprise est là elle dormait
bas bien sûr c'est la surprise
et puis c'est lé pas parti c'est qu'elle
était complètement tétanisés par cet
acte un incompréhensible pour une femme
d'être violées donc d'être prise pour un
objet vous parler de cette loi mais
votre livre édifiant à ce propos
violence sexuelle en finir avec
l'impunité aux éditions dunod que vous
avez codirigé avec édouard du rang qui
est le coprésident de la commission sur
l'inceste les violences sexuelles faites
aux enfants
l'idh
et de dire que malgré cette loi malgré
tout et bien il ya énormément de
classement sans suite et des peines qui
ne sont pas lourdes pour les agresseurs
comment l'expliquer on a donc cette
classement sur dix de plein donc c'est
énorme
et bien parce que je pense que on ne
prend pas suffisamment en compte la
parole la parole de la victime première
éléments deuxième élément est bien c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur les
auditions
ainsi on veut arriver à pouvoir faire la
preuve d'une agression sexuelle ou d'un
viol eh bien il faut faire de bonne
audition pour avoir derrière de bonnes
enquêtes ce sera les derniers mots de
cette émission merci beaucoup ernestine
ronai de d'avoir évoqué votre combat
contre les violences faites aux femmes
contre les féminicides je rappelle que
vous êtes membre du haut conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
je vous invite à retrouver l'intégralité
de cette émission sur arte france point
tv merci de votre fidélité à bientôt sur
arte france
[Musique]